we're joined now by Bob Cusack
editor-in-chief of the hill for some
perspective on this and other stories
Bob good morning good morning as you
heard the president say it's going to
court happily we'll win
I think Willie and how long does this
play out it's gonna be tough I mean this
is a huge separation of powers issue and
legal experts are a bit split on it but
at the same time the fact that the
president has been saying this has been
an emergency for weeks and weeks and
weeks that's got to hurt his case and
also I think it also depends Congress is
gonna be moving a resolution of
disapproval here if that is gonna be a
very partisan vote if that somehow
passes and it could pass the Senate as
it's definitely passed the house that
could actually hurt him in court because
everybody is split over this issue it's
not an emergency they'll say that's what
Democrats his own words could hurt him
in court we just we heard them they've
been played a lot since yesterday I
didn't need to do this I'd rather do it
much faster yes now that's how we're
gonna be cited in the court so I think
this is a very risky situation for the
president but he was boxed in and
honestly they should have been moving
the mall the wall when he was first
elected because I had the house and the
Senate and the way how much of a split
is this cause within the GOP do you
think Bob I think significant I mean I
think most of the Senate Republicans are
gonna back their president but Marco
Rubio has said this is a terrible idea
and he this is gonna be a tough vote
because the vote in the Senate that's
going to be happening in the coming
weeks
you can't filibuster it so if you have a
handful of defections in the Senate with
all the Democrats or most of Democrats
Joe Manchin maybe votes with the
Republicans then this will go to the
president he can veto it but that would
be embarrassing
so there's 2020 political cycle here the
Democrats are you know they all think
alike or at least that seems to be the
case in what we see how will immigration
play into you know this there speak I
think it's gonna be interesting because
the comprehensive immigration reform
bill that passed the Senate years ago
had a lot of border security in it now
Democrats are saying hey we know but
we're not we're not big in a border
security now federal work said he wants
to tear some walls down so that's the
challenge is that you've got to stand
out in a crowd and maybe you have to go
more to the left and then Republicans
seized on you as extreme that's their
playbook for 22
the Republicans does this remain sort of
one of the issues obviously for the
president it was one of the issues he
campaigned on it became a bigger issue
then a lot of people saw it being
initially so in 2020 does this remain
one of the top issues oh yes the wall is
not going away and he will say we've
made progress but we need to finish it
and that's why you got a real like me in
2020 you know let's turn to us-china
trade relations about what can you tell
us it we're getting closer to this March
1st deadline yeah where are things well
I think that the president Trump has
hinted that he could push this deadline
back there's no it's an artificial
self-imposed deadline no they're saying
they're making progress people on Wall
Street watching this very closely we
talked to Republican senators they are
very nervous about these tariffs so I
think that there it seems to be making
progress but you don't know what spin
and what's reality is there a line in
the sand though for members of his own
party because on some of these issues
that are key to the Republican platform
they're there they're falling aside on
it
yeah and Trump can't lose the economy
here if he loses the economy in 2020
remember there a lot of Republican
senators who are up in 2020 they're
getting nervous so that's there's
incentive for Trump to strike a deal
because he needs the economy to stay
strong without a doubt we always talk
about Trump's base what about the rest
of the Republican Party and we were just
talking this morning that he has the
rest of the Republican Party on his side
is there anything is the wall the issue
would China be the issue is there
somewhere where maybe the rest of the
party sort of goes astray I think it
depends on what happens the rest of the
Congress I mean is he gonna strike any
deals with Democrats on infrastructure
or drug pricing can he win some of the
independents that he won in 2016 but
he's lost since the election I think
that's gonna be the key the way this
Congress has started with the shutdown I
think it's highly unlikely wouldn't get
some big bipartisan deals that was my
question
yeah what will we see in the bipartisan
arena with the with a backdrop of
possible impeachment proceedings yeah
all right Bob q snick thanks so much for
being with us this morning thank you